welcome to the man of recaps this is the
walking dead season 11 episode 11. this
episode mostly features everyone's
favorite nerdy weird talker eugene yeah
he's living the dream with his new
girlfriend stephanie who's so perfect
she even encouraged him to write a
science fiction novel and they take a
big step today eugene says i love you
and oh she says it back so life is good
they're meeting up for ice cream later
eugene orders two before she even gets
there like a psychopath i mean those are
gonna melt but stephanie never shows yes
for reasons unknown stephanie has
disappeared without a trace princess
comes to help out her friend she brings
him an empty lasagna dish she didn't
actually want to make lasagna but eugene
knows stephanie wouldn't leave him it's
much more likely there's a vast
government conspiracy eugene's best lead
is this tough-looking guy he saw coming
out of stephanie's apartment building
that day allegedly he's a plumber but
eugene's been surveilling his workplace
and it definitely seems shady he and
princess break into snoop around they
don't find plumbing supplies but do find
a secret agent spy kit unfortunately
though they are not good spies and we're
caught breaking in lance hornsby comes
to get him out like you guys again he's
like look eugene you're chasing ghosts
that guy's just a plumber and stephanie
just left eugene's freddie go as long as
he signs the statement sorry i was
depressed and crazy meanwhile new
commonwealth reporter sisters connie and
kelly are digging for the truth about
the guy who freaked out at the halloween
party their boss gives him the classic
stop chasing that story just report what
i tell ya but you know connie's not
giving up and turns out mercer has a
particular interest in this guy because
the woman he took hostage pamela
milton's assistant is actually his
sister anyway their investigations hit a
dead end but someone slips a note under
their door with a list of names on it
hoo-hoo the mystery deepens by the way
they do still manage to work in some
zombies every episode this time a group
of soldiers are ambushed and this guy is
just like really not impressive but it's
one of the coolest shots ever when
mercer axes the zombie head and as we
pan out we see that he took out the
whole group of them single-handedly
carol's also in this episode hanging out
with her new friend lance hornsby she
proved she's smart and resourceful so
lance hornsby takes her along on an
official unofficial mission outside the
official commonwealth is a poppy farm
where they get morphine for the hospital
and also of course drugs long story
short carol figures out the boss here is
skimming off the top and beating his
wives so lance won't be dazz him
arrested and carol saved the day but now
back to eugene he is not giving up he
goes snooping around some more and guess
who he finds hanging out with the fake
plumbers it is stephanie without her
glasses she avoids him though she
doesn't want to deal with this and
leaves it to her boss lance hornsby yes
turns out eugene's lady love stephanie
is not real she's a secret agent working
in lance horn's bcia whose job was to
get close to eugene to learn all about
their group once he declared his love
for her it was like oh this has gone too
far we gotta pull the plug eugene is
super mad but hornsby's like hey man
sorry we broke your heart but you know
just standard spycraft and yeah fake
stephanie doesn't actually love you but
she did love your sci-fi book it was
really good man but eugene falls into a
deep depression he's sitting in an alley
way burning his manuscript but behind
him someone wants to talk and she knows
the radio call signs that he and
stephanie used it is mercer's sister
pamela milton's assistant who claims she
was the woman talking to eugene on the
radio oh snap a big reveal it's unclear
if her real name is stephanie so maybe
after this epic heartbreak eugene's lady
love is real after all and that's where
episode 11 comes to an end
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]